[Music]
new year who dis
have you ever written that text yeah i
ironically new phone who dis that's how
it started do you know i almost posted
an instagram i couldn't sleep one night
and i was awake when the sun was rising
uh-huh oh that's the way i almost posted
a picture that said new day who dis i'm
surprised that i didn't or that i
thought that you know that you almost
did that although i guess it would have
been funny that is funny
okay i don't know um
do you hear what i just did you know
people who do that when they're like
they have a new thought they want to
like
it's like you want to like clean the
slate last night
you go
they like suck yeah
oh god
i don't know how i'm gonna function in
the non-pandemic world again it's gonna
take me a while to prepare myself for it
i've gotten
so accustomed to not being
around people
like i've been shortening things would
you talking about this today i'll
shorten things like i'm gonna make some
din i asked if you wanted a salad and i
called the sauce out
oh god
i mean we were doing that for a while to
be like funny i guess and like it's
gross it's a problem and then you it
gets into your version
exactly sometimes you
say something as a joke long enough that
it eventually becomes real well whatever
it's a new year speaking of it being a
new year i am so excited to start this
year off
with this guest and uh you know what i i
feel like that was a fun introduction so
let's talk about why
after the opening credits
wow changes
not for the
better life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your
host new 2021 me life
[Music]
with me as always
is my
slightly more focused but still hasn't
gone out of the rut of 2020 christian
brother happy new year happy new year to
you yeah i feel like
this guest today who whom we'll
introduce in a second do you say whom or
who will introduce i always get this
wrong me too
i think it's who we'll introduce you
know what i'll get i'll be better about
that in 2022 that'll be a i already have
so many resolutions this year right
grammar can't be won
um another one
towards and toward i have a hard time
with too
i was going toward him towards who's our
guest today okay well before i say that
he relates in a very big way in my life
to 2020. so it's a nice way i think it's
a nice way to start the new year because
a big part of my 2020 was
staying home you know and quarantining
watching shows and what i watched i
think more than anything um
were two things in practical jokers and
portlandia the show portlandia brought
me
so much joy i had seen i of course had
seen it before i'd done an episode of it
but i i never watched it start to finish
i did that in the quarantine and god it
made me happy god is a funny show and
our guest today
is one of the co-creators and the stars
of that show one of the most brilliant
comedic minds
fred armisen
fred's got to be top five funniest of
all time i think it's hard to rank i
know people like that i know it's hard
to rank him or put him in any category
because he's so unique so many
characters he's played and so many
comedic points of view yeah he was one
of the great snl cast members for many
years how long was he on that show 10
years something like that and so many
people so many snl cast members i've
talked to not only on the show but
everyone cites him as their favorites
he's like a favorite among cast members
just because what he did was so it was
such a
departure from what they had been doing
was a lot more absurdist
um and
specific stuff that he does you know it
wasn't like these broader characters
which i love like massive head wound
harry and and
uh wayne's world took me back oh yeah
that in oh really the dana carvey decade
at least i love those characters the
ones that were like you don't both have
to love the snl years you grew up on
or even like the rob schneider like they
got big i mean they got old but like i
can't even say it without saying it got
old everyone knows that got old right is
that still fresh to anyone even rob
schneider i'm sure is like oh man i did
that one time i feel like people haven't
thought about that in a while so if you
saw one of those sketches now you might
be
transported to a
happy time in your life and it might not
feel old that's true but what fred retro
now that's true um but what fred did on
snl and what he continued to do on
portlandia it was so
uh
there was something so real about it and
and specific it was so like nuanced um i
just marvel at some of those portlandia
sketches i i'm still not totally done
with the series and
it's one of those things where like i
know i'm coming up on the end and it's
making me a little sad so i'm spacing
them out over the course of a couple
days it's so great god yeah and so we
talk about that and um we just catch up
about life and
how he came to be i was so curious
to know more about him because he's
someone i've known for quite some time
and you know i've never had occasion to
like really sit down and pick his brain
well i'm jumping at the point okay all
right let's hear it here we go uh
my my talk my chi chat with the
i never know how to say it
that hasn't changed in the new year i i
don't know what has changed
well i've become a rambling and you know
what it is you've gotten a little bit
more confident
in being bad in being sloppy
that's and maybe i've gotten a little
more
judgmental
maybe i don't know i don't know i
haven't heard the earlier episodes but
i'm just reacting to what you're giving
me oh you know we didn't press record
did you think for a second i did yeah
and i thought were you like
maybe not the worst
wouldn't thing the worst thing that that
[ __ ] crack at this point yeah that
bit backfired
um
you were about to be like oh good
for the better okay here we go uh let's
stop talking well how long
who wants to hear us anymore i know we
got your arms we got your legend legend
here he is the legend one of my favorite
comedic minds fred arms
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
if you listen you know what a fan i am
of yours and of of the show of portland
everything you do and and this thing
that you're doing now
is this jonathan chrysler's id was it
something he wrote and he just called
you no it for real was it came from a
text chain tim heidecker was on
portlandia i think with nina and lance
oh he was an exterminator he was like a
an eco-friendly exterminator
and on set we were just having
such a good time we just started this
text chain and i've worked with him and
i've worked with john c o'reilly before
and we just
started saying we should do a show and
it really we just kept going and going
and then eventually we had this idea to
do it about a moon base i think john c
reilly came up with like why don't we do
it like we're on getting ready to go to
the moon it was one of those first
thoughts that
i really don't think we searched around
too much like i think it was one of the
first things and then chrysler you know
how great he is i mean he's just so
brilliant and and
he he's worked with those guys before so
it was all but in the family it made a
lot of sense yeah and um
they both really make me laugh i can see
you all having a similar sensibility
yeah yeah like um
it's something like that chilling so
fast and then in terms of getting it
made is it is it as easy as
it's you guys and so you go to whomever
i mean is it just like where do we go
with this and it's gonna get made well
it's a double thing yes we got very
lucky that it got made because a24 did
it without having a network behind it
this is such showbiz talking
i kind of i kind of don't mind showbiz i
don't need him
yeah i'm just like it's the business
world yeah i know i always feel
apologetic about it
yeah you know i'm supposed to talk about
agencies and stuff like well what do you
want from me and this is what's
happening
um
824
did the whole series no pilot like all
six episodes wow without any network and
then we pitched it around for i want to
say a couple of years maybe a year and a
half maybe a couple years no one took it
you're kidding and
my guess is that
when you present someone with something
they have no choices in it's probably
not that enticing to say we shot it
already so any notes you have are
impossible yes and those people they
love giving they love feeling like they
have some sort of hand in the yeah
process
even any little thing
it's
shot oh you finished it oh my god
no we finished it all it was all a24 wow
wow but then showtime took it so then
showtime it took them a little while but
i think the pandemic helped
there was just less around and also
the vibe of it is different now the show
is about there's quarantining in it
we're isolated on this moon base we're
just training to go to the moon the
whole thing is like we're not good
astronauts and other people keep
training with us and then going to the
moon
we're like why is it that like
who are these
hot shots coming in and then like we're
like
that's really funny
um and um
so so
because we're in these like rooms just
alone it's oddly
the timing was good
that so it all worked out yeah we're
just going to use that sound bite uh
we're going to take you the pandemic
timing was really good for us worked out
yeah it's worth it all works worth all
the all the
the virus and all that
and it ended up being for the past
we'll we'll stitch it we'll frankenstein
it too we sound like a monster
where did you shoot moon base that was
just in the valley or even
even further out christ was so fast did
is he did he yeah is it like that was it
like the way you shot port landings yeah
really really fast and it's just two
sets so we shot all the interiors in
this one part of valley in this
warehouse wow and then out in this like
foundry
that looked like that all this sand and
stuff he's he's great yeah he's
incredible i had you worked with john c
this is i'm sure you have worked with
john cena but i'm i'm yeah yeah i did a
movie with him in like 2000 i don't know
six or something or five and
um called the promotion what was it five
or six i know i knew you're gonna get me
on this
i knew it i knew it i just i'm not gonna
answer
i'm not gonna answer you buddy that's
not i asked the tough questions
by the way isn't it weird thinking back
to years like that i'm like what the
hell was 2005 i know i have no concept
i'm like no i guess i had an ipod i
think
no i know i had an iphone i know there's
certain like touchstones that like yeah
i guess technology like
those flip phones seem so archaic now
but i guess we had those
i don't really remember 2005 was a
little more aptly it's a little more
yeah it was my party like the tick tick
tick tick tick tick one yeah yeah uh
what but what
like i don't think we were all texting
as much no no sir you know what's funny
i was talking to john hodgman with whom
i did the
apple piece he reminded me that when we
started those commercials we were
shooting obviously against this like
white expanse you know and like there
wasn't much time to go back to the
trailers and we would all
talk the whole crew and cast we would
all laugh and like talk and it was so
communal there was something so uh it
was really nice the way to socialize he
said when the iphone came out almost
immediately
he got on twitter
i would look on the new you know people
just went to their things and it like
the whole yeah the socializing
changed on set and of course now it's
like completely
it's affected all of society but
i remember right what years did you it
was years did you do that it was 2006 to
2010 and i think the iphone
there you go yeah yeah it was like
yeah
i certainly didn't think this was going
to change ever you know i had no
uh but i remember john saying things
like that like this is going to change
everything and because he was much more
plugged into technology innovation and
uh i remember people saying it a lot
people say like no this is very very
different yeah and then i i'm kind of a
sucker for people say it something
enough i'm going i guess this is like
where everything is headed yes yeah it's
true especially with technology
i've also been watching portlandia i've
been going back and re-watching just
every episode and so i've been seeing
the changes on that that like the
iphones change a little bit yeah
the things that you guys were
highlighting the absurd parts of society
like when everyone was djing and um yes
because you guys had your fingers on the
on the pulse of like
the absurd parts of uh culture these
cultural shifts um
and that's why i felt like i said to
carrie something like a podcast feels
like that it feels like an episode of
portlandia where i was like oh so
everyone's asking me to do their podcast
everyone has one
it could have been a sketch yeah i think
there is a zone where
yeah it could have been sort of like
people just asking each other until it's
like one huge like why don't we do a
podcast the episode is everyone on at
the same time
the whole audience has one a
stadium you just get a stadium like
everyone set up your mics we are all
yeah yeah it's funny is that how uh
which youth what is it was as simple as
writing on that show was it as simple as
uh
recognizing in an absurd element of
something and then just running with it
yeah it's i really
that's something
that was really fun about writing
because
we're all friends but you know we with a
very traditional writer's room like we
actually sat around the table
and
we would talk about things it's almost
like everyone became like a little
stand-up comedian so we'd have a list on
our phone would say like i noticed when
i go to the airport
you know blank happens ah
sometimes people wouldn't react but
sometimes
someone would answer well yes i noticed
the same thing and then all of a sudden
you're just building and building
and i'm sure that's how many writers
rooms work but there's something about
this that was very like this is
happening now i noticed this
well probably so different than like snl
um where it was wouldn't you guys kind
of pair off into
there would be more assignment it would
be more assignment based snl was more
like whims
so you know there's there's topical
stuff there's like whatever's in the
news
and then once in a while there'll be a
like a cast member will have a character
like you know i was thinking what about
this character who always has an
umbrella i don't know just some some
thing
and then that cast member and the writer
will just go and write it and try to
turn it into something that's a little
less immediately topical because we just
didn't have a luxury you know it would
be like another nine months before we
ever saw the episode so we didn't
couldn't do anything too topical so we
had to try to find an area where it
would be current but you know not the
week's news
i'm thinking now i'm the one i'm on now
is the one where uh chloe seven you
moves in with you guys and she's and
she's she's kind of like co-opting all
of these like cool aspects of different
cultures and uh
something like that to me is so
relatable in the sense that
you know you're always trying to build
up people who
may not be as smart as you or as as
funny as you or but for superficial
reasons you're um
you're building them up and you're
convincing yourself uh
something like that strikes me as just
like
it's not at all dependent on on time
it's very relatable so universal that
one i remember i think and i honestly
don't remember who one of us was going
through something like that where
i can't remember who it was but it was
like we were talking about when you're
dating someone and it was actually very
specifically about musical tastes
so i know it's a snobby place to come
from yeah but a place of like where you
like someone enough that if they like
something that's you're just like that's
my thing but yeah okay and by the way
i'm sure i'm that person for somebody
else i mean it's just yeah yeah but it
was it was very specifically music that
bad country that's what kerry said she
thought your
if not your main motivation for doing
the show like certainly like a real
driving force was was
uh exploring music and exploring like uh
the comedic elements of the musical
world and and incorporating music into
sketch yeah just because that whole
world there's plenty there yeah
especially the sort of indie rock or
punk rock world yeah just between
recording studios and other bands or
people who sell guitars it's just a
simple thing of like i think there's i
think there are a lot of characters here
i think there are a lot of there's also
personality traits that are like
international totally there's just very
specific things we just wrote about what
we knew yeah sure and then working with
carrie is like
you know she's so brilliant and so funny
that she was just perfect to do this but
she just has a really analytical
view of it yes for me it was more like
like drawing out a caricature but for
her
she
just looked at the sort of social impact
of whatever kind of character that was i
i forget exactly what she studied in
college but it was like um it was
linguistics
linguistics
it was
and it was perfect i was like oh of
course do you remember the moment that
you thought
oh
we could do something like this together
yeah
you know like when i first met her
i knew the drummer i knew janet weiss i
remember
and there was a real thing of just
feeling it i just felt like ah this i
think we're we're gonna get along
i don't know what it is it's like
i it could be chemical was something i
was like i think we're gonna get which
we did yeah
talk some more talk some more and then
somewhere in there i i found myself
laughing a lot
and
when we decided to start doing videos
you know there's we could have made
music or made videos and and video
seemed a little more
of a good challenge when you're in a
band it's just like it's not that
amazing like we both pick up guitars hey
i can't believe we played a song
this is a little more like what's this
going to be
and we did our our first video
was something where we did an intro
this is for thundering first video this
is pre-portlandia and the intro was
carrie
wiping off graffiti off of the wall
there was real good feeding it was she
started turning to the camera so she's
wiped and she went like this
you know saying no
i had no idea graffiti is wrong
and in that moment
it was the perfect it was exactly what i
want to be around with comedy i was like
that is
what whatever this is a show this
friendship
her doing that she doesn't play it like
um
i'm a funny person she doesn't do that
like this is comedy
it's so real and so uh yeah it just
comes from this place that like it made
immediate sense
and it felt right and now it still feels
right i'm like oh man i'll never forget
when i saw that i was like that's all
you know this is this is there that
makes sense for it because you find
those moments uh trying to think of like
i just saw the punk at the absolute
where they're touring the house with the
and you play the spike is it spot not so
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and there's a
certain thing like
why don't you take a picture and you
know there's certain
there's certain subtleties that like
were you always just drawn to
moments like that and chara you you say
they're characters but you must uh be
able to identify those characters in a
way you must always have been able to do
that um i think that because my
family moved around a little bit my
dad's
german and my mom's venezuelan yeah and
um
we lived in brazil for a little while my
mom has been as well like spanish
speaking
really speaking spanish wow uh partially
you know part of the time so yeah i
think some somewhere in traveling
and going to new schools i i'm this is
by the way total guesswork yeah i think
there's an element of like okay what is
this environment what language is this
uh
how you know then we moved to new york
which was so different suburban new york
is like very different than
brazil brazilian it's sort of uh it was
a sort of working class or upper middle
class kind of yeah
new york you know yeah um
it's a little bit of that that kind of
thing where like there was just a lot of
accents and mannerisms going around and
did you find yourself having to then
like assimilate to a whole new group of
people too was so was humor a way that
you did that or were you a quiet kid
what kind of kid were you i
i was um very friendly uh i liked
mimicking things in people i don't think
i was like a clown like i wasn't right
i
needed to be funny to relate to people
it's none of that nothing like that
i had my group of friends i feel like we
were all kind of like weird in our own
way and it just went from there and i
always loved music so that even when you
were little
oh yeah
drums specifically drums yeah yeah very
very specifically and
as soon as i like heard like a full drum
kit really being played
i was focused yeah i want to say fourth
grade maybe or something oh wow what for
up from oh yeah
music in the house that was being played
in the house you're any brazilian yeah
music being played in the house and my
mom would uh well my mom also bought me
beetle records so i hear all these
beatles records and hearing ringo and
going from there to other bands and then
but i was yeah i was a kid and i loved
it fred this keeps coming up in my life
i don't know why but it was ringo i hear
two different things about ringo was he
um
i i've heard that he's an incredible
drummer like one of the best and then he
also heard that he was not in fact to
the point where like i heard a story
where he would leave the uh he would go
out for a smoke or something they they'd
call like a fake break a fake uh and he
would go out and they would stay and
have a session drummer come in
and and do the track and then when he
would come back and hear it played back
you go oh it was pretty good it's not
bad you know i'm not in the beatles
organization but i will say the second
thing is definitely not true okay
only because those guys you know the
rest of them are such songwriting
geniuses i don't think they would why
would they pick a guy why would they're
not about that fan wasn't about that
sleekness
expression yeah and
i actually think it's a myth that people
disagree that if ringo's a good drummer
or not i think when you talk to drummers
even privately drummers say that guy was
brilliant he's expressive and
this is a rock band
it's rock and roll drumming you take for
granted the feeling you get when you
hear the beginning of i'm the walrus or
sergeant pepper or a day in the life
when those films come in we everyone
everybody is moved when those drums come
in
and also the idea of being a musician is
like your signature when you know it's
someone when you know it's
eddie van gaalin or whoever
you know that that's ringo that what he
did for those songs is the ultimate of
success of being a drummer also that
that was like a they were like a tight
band
i know together the way you talk about
music and i know how passionate you are
about it was it difficult to not do that
full-time i mean after you you were in a
successful band in the 90s
no not successful oh very easy oh no we
did a lot of tours to not very many
people oh
i mean it depends on how you see success
i had someone from a band tell me that i
was wrong that like success is like
learning successes traveling the country
and
playing a lot of drums so in its own way
there was a lot of success and also
those are my friends i i got to know
them better and we joked around a lot so
it all informed i wouldn't change
anything i'll put it this way as
compared to my dreams
where i was like i wanted us to be as
big as
bigger bands
no we did not sell those records we did
not play those huge venues i don't have
the experience of having a hit record
was that frustrating
did there come a point where you were
like
you got tired of the road oh yeah it was
very
it was rough because i banked on it
inside i was like oh yeah no um there's
the clash and then we're getting there
believe me
and
and it's very evident when it's not
happening it's very evident because
it's very physical to show up set up
your drums right do a sound check right
this is about i don't know 18 people
here i think five of them leave we had
some great shows some of them but
compared to also our friends people we
we knew well
would have radio hits or whatever
alternative radio hits there was a point
actually where there's a binge because
this band was in chicago
where there was
i was like well we're artsy that's why
we're not
on the radio we're just a little weirder
yeah this band
out of chicago called tortoise
was all instrumental they were an
instrumental band and they were huge
they were our friends and i was like oh
i'm done
one what do i have to do i was like this
is not working which is i gotta say so
we stopped and
i got
i got a credit sometimes to the idea of
failure failure is kind of like a
could be a really good thing to accept
it yeah and it kind of worked out for me
yeah
for like
i'll put it this way i don't it's not
like i'm the most brilliant drummer in
the world i'm not like no one got to see
my i'm i've seen drummers you are very
good i mean i i know i'm just fine i'm
you know
ringo said that
i'm okay you know i'm not saying right
on my bedroom but i've met drummers who
are like
really dedicated to their craft who
really
really are good at uh tempo and like the
sound of their drums and their life is
drums and that's not me
there are plenty of great drummers the
three fans that that made it i think
were the bands that should have made it
those are great bands i know but can you
say that i mean i wouldn't say that
about you and actors but i think about
myself and sometimes i'll see a
performance like i look at like john c
reilly playing dr steve bruhl and i
think
i could never
do that i could never be that committed
and that uh
i could never be that funny i i just
know that i'm not saying that in a way
that's like being self-deprecating or
fish i just know that i accept that but
it still
i wouldn't be okay if i didn't get to
act after this you know i wouldn't be
okay if it all dried up i'd still
really want be like yearned yeah and
then i still get to drum you know
somehow
it made its way into my life that is
true i get to play on seth's show and
yeah i did a couple of things on snl
playing the drums so it all because i
loved drums so much it
weirdly worked out where i got to play
and write music plenty right anyway
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
the acceptance of this not working out
did that how directly did that coincide
with you then getting into sketch and
acting somehow around that time i was
playing drums for blue man group this
off-broadway show that was in chicago
and um i started making videos these
like sort of comedy videos and
because some of it was me interviewing
artists and stuff and
little by little that started getting
more attention than my band did all of a
sudden i was showing it at clubs and i
just found that like more and more
things were happening is related to
comedy so then all of a sudden there'd
be another uh sorry to call it a gate
but another gig a comedy and something
else and then something else
and
very quickly that's all i was doing it
was all comedy it just oh and it just
went there quickly weird and it was
never anything like as a kid and even in
high school you flirted with the idea of
doing or you enjoyed doing plays or well
a little bit in that like what i was
always drawn to was
music that was very sort of visual and
that had like a sort of weird you know
stuff like devo you can't classify them
as comedy they're definitely a fun fan
but
what's what's that thing they're doing
whatever it is that they were doing is
what you know the way that mark
motherboard the singer was
i i want that's what i wanted to be like
there's something in there that i i
really like david byrne to an extent
yeah yeah performance
yeah uh that performative
and so so and this was also a thing that
lorne
uh once you were on snl was there a
sense that you weren't um
was portlandia kind of born out of not
being able to
be as absurdist as you'd like on snow
was there just an element of your comedy
that you felt like
you you wanted to explore in a way that
snl
wasn't the right forum for
no like i it was a little more
of about what's next
it was very like um i think there was a
literal question that my manager asked
that he was like what do you want to do
next i've been making these videos with
carrie
there was no pressure on it so we made
these videos
because i gotta say snl
really did let me do some weird
stuff anyway they were very like
there was never a problem when they were
like yeah that's not mainstream enough
you know
um and then uh
with carrie it was more like
this seems like a good direction to go
it was a very like light decision it was
very like
let's start doing this more huh because
it was fun i mean it must have just been
it was as simple as oh it's this is just
fun this is just makes sense
yeah it makes sense and i you know
love getting to be around kerry and
working with her and stuff my favorite
band to this day is still sleeter kenny
her band i was obsessed with them i was
like um and
you know still
yeah
love them yeah so
something in that guitar playing
ah man it sounds too pretentious but no
no fred i can hear you hearing it and
it's not it's not it's coming from a
place of like
there's an innocence to your affection
for music and and hers and i think it's
really nice
what and and i didn't get to explore
with her how what a brilliant guitar
player she is because um
i that's not how i know her as well you
know um and so selfishly wasn't as i
just wasn't as
uh drawn to that but but i know and then
i talked to musicians and they're like
oh no no she was
she's one of the best and one of them oh
no
she's one of the best yeah like
she's up there and also in a very real
way not in a sort of way of like
perfunctory it's like a very like moving
guitar play yeah well for somebody who
was such a fan and was so
found her to be so impressive uh
it must have been i can only imagine
when you met her and you saw how she
behaved you must have been so like
disarmed by how
cool and kind of down to earth how she
doesn't carry herself that way at all
you know no no you must have been really
impressed by that
it was i mean i think you know the whole
band are like that yeah totally they
live in they live in portland and yeah i
was i'm friends with um
corin and lance corrin's
the other guitar player and and her
husband lance i just
i i've known them as friends for a
really long time so she's in that group
of people and she's like them
fred did you have a lot of experience in
portland i know kerry had lived there
but were you how familiar were you with
the whole
that whole subculture of portland austin
it's a subculture that like
visible in portland you know when i
would go visit there but like i knew it
in chicago a little bit chicago had a
bit of that and minneapolis oh yeah so
when i was in chicago we'd go to
minneapolis and minneapolis like
in st hall
there were a couple cafes that were in
that whatever that's called that world
is there's a couple of these cafes that
were sort of
where you could feel the same thing
happening so what portland is about and
was about i i saw a bit of it in chicago
yeah
it's funny yeah it started kind of
springing up in most cities there'd be
like a pocket of that yeah yeah whatever
that is it's it it's like i would just
call it like a portlandia pocket now
yeah yeah
yeah
and going back retroactively minneapolis
and chicago had a very like industrial
vibe to it meaning like
a lot of like you know work jackets yeah
cats and
yeah you know glasses and
you know i'm making this up but i feel
like tattoos of coffee cups kind of
thing like i think i knew one guy with
it but i picture everyone everyone
having that tattoo yeah well this song
that the sketch that embodies that the
best is the um
is the song i mean it's it's the the
dream of the 90s is alive and yeah it's
like i that kind of like yeah a lot of
the things by the way you you guys did
satirize um
i you know i do this with a lot of
things that i love that were made
10 15 years ago
i every once in a while something will
come on that strikes me um as being so
obviously you can't do that anymore you
know or like i i it's not even worth
coming up with an example of in portland
but i'm but every once in a while i'll
notice that do you
do you think now is the culture too
sensitive for that kind of satire is
satire too hard to do now or
will there always be a way to do it
in my opinion like in the history of
comedy it just always changes yeah and
that's okay maybe it's good the way you
satirize anything that changes
is kind of like that's just how it's
always been that's okay and it's okay
also if like entertainment is temporary
i think
did you guys ever face that in uh on the
show on portland when um were there ever
things that you felt you had either gone
too far with or couldn't go further
you'd like to go further was there ever
i mean i'm trying to think of an example
yeah
a little well that stuff ended up
getting cut all right we would do
sketches and
you can just feel it there we go that we
felt like who's turning out to be like
who are we really kind of like who ends
up looking like we're like we're making
fun of them right kind
and
it was it's luckily we always agreed oh
that's just an amazing feeling you're
like you know
who are we bringing down here what is
this about and then
we'd do something and then just cut it
just just from feeling you must miss it
i miss it
yeah i mean i missed it but
i'm so glad
it was a
solid eight years
right i'm glad that we didn't trickle
away i'm glad that like there wasn't a
two-year break or some weird thing it's
like the beatles like the beatles i love
that yeah and it actually
strengthens our relationship because
then when i see her it it all it is is
the friendship hey we you know here we
are yeah yeah and also like it's not
like you exhausted each other's company
like you were no
yeah you were half that's great none of
that
thank god like that's
it had a nice you know nice finish to it
also that we made the decision it wasn't
made for us
right exactly that would be you never
got the call of like we're stopping your
show or you know you're cancelled and
there's not enough ratings not that i
know how i got our ratings but it was
never a business decision like that we
couldn't function anymore it was like
this is our last year
and and and and was that the result of
you could just sense is it the same we
were talking about there was a cohesion
that allowed you to know when not to go
after somebody or when something was
funny was was there that similar sense
that like
this feels like it's not run its course
but we
it's no longer we're not it's we're no
longer percolating in the way that we
want to
yeah it's kind of like
it's a weird thing of like
we made the decision a couple years
before i don't even know why we're like
yeah i'll probably go another couple
years yeah and then it became real like
one more year and then all of a sudden
it was so official that we're like oh i
guess this is it
it was more like that
which worked out great eight years i
think it's a long a good run that's a
good solid oh it's amazing yeah yeah and
i'm i'm seeing
just been going back and there's scott
they're so fun and they're all on
netflix now i don't know if people know
that but uh
yeah
by the way you're involved you're
excellent oh buddy i went to hang around
it was so fun that was such a treat for
me i'm such a fan of that show i um
uh i i gotta ask you about the guy who
asks the question at the paul simon
concert that's that's one of the many
portlandia characters where i i think oh
my god
i i know that character i know that
person
i i've we've all seen that person uh
was there a specific event
that inspired that guy the one who who
just loves hearing himself ask the
question
it's everything you've ever been to it's
been
yeah like press event you've done or
like a q a
and yeah i think
and you know nothing against them but
like
a lot of people just want to
sort of advertise what they do
yeah because i'm a director and i've
been doing this and i was you know
you can tell because they're not
listening to the answer they'll ask yeah
i'm saying and i'm like you're not even
listening to the answers oh i
yeah my brother and i we listen
we listen to a lot of uh sports radio
we're in in like the tri-state area in
new york and that's every caller every
caller yeah i got something to say i got
two things to say yeah and they don't
want to hear the feedback they're
questions but they're not really they're
not questions they just advertise what
they know they're it's so good um
and nicholas fain where where did
nicholas fain come from one of my other
that was kind of like um
a combo between
you know a lot of my stand-up was in l.a
largo oh yeah
yeah yeah and i would see
mark maron there and like david cross
there
and it's like it's a kind of mix between
the two oh so mark maron being like i
think i remember him having like a army
jacket
and then
david cross
who i i'm a fan of oh yeah i mean it's
just you know that goes without saying i
mean
these guys are the you know the greatest
yeah
um it's a way that david would
sometimes uh end some of his jokes is
with the half a sentence yes so he'd say
like
i went to the airport and uh there was a
you know
someone was wearing a
you know hockey helmet you can't
you can't you know
no
no no you can't i mean who are the
people
who even
yeah okay it's so good
um
yeah do you
with that type of comedy is that
something that you
will continue to do on stage will you
continue to do that in your stand up i
don't know what to do about that because
like i've been doing
a lot of stand-up the last couple years
if someone requests it i'll do it i kind
of don't want to become someone
who is
just you know putting on like a wig and
like yeah
i'm happy to do it if someone requests
it but if i lean into things like hey
remember that right i know that's i
think that's not good i think yeah for
me for me yeah for some people it's
great
but i don't want to be someone saying
remember this
no yeah i just love those characters
certain characters you did so much that
i that i selfishly i project onto you
that i selfishly assume that you love
them so much that you want to keep doing
them you know
i would do them like if someone ever
asks me like on the street i'll do it in
a second i always do um oh really people
do that to you on the street
oh absolutely you know we make a video
from my friend and do it in this
character i don't care i don't think
it's just about it oh absolutely yeah
that's cool yeah
so nice and or if i'm doing stand up and
someone says hey will you do this
not a problem but if i got a wig and i'm
like
if i do that i worry that because you
know i'm only going to look older and
older
and then
somewhere there will be a photo
you know what i mean like yeah what's
this from oh that's when he was doing
that character and then he had to have
like a
you know a bigger way
you know it's not first for some people
i've seen it work i've seen people do it
and they do it great i really have yeah
yeah
for me i just i think i'm i i don't feel
like doing it that way fred this is
gonna be real uh we have a lightning
round uh really quick okay
um what is your most do you use emojis
yeah i do yeah what is your most
commonly used one would you say like
your go-to i'm gonna punctuate this with
a
i like the applause one
oh yeah yeah
so i'll do like a few of those sometimes
yeah um
and by the way because this is a
lightning round i was trying to think of
like what's a cool thing to say and i'm
like fred really seriously what's the
what's what do you really do
when you
you've got to put the phone down i'll
usually do a plugs as a sort of
that's
that's interesting you say that right
because i
yeah people do answer this uh approach
this one of two ways and one is to like
you want to come up with i that's what i
would do i want to come up with like a
cool answer you know yeah what's funny
the green glove
yes
the recycle sign the
the microscope
yeah
sure the globe the globe but on the
african side
like no you don't
um
if
the the flag of bolivia um if you could
be a professional athlete what sport
would you play
man lightning round lightning round
tennis okay i don't know why i don't
know it just came that's just what i
thought tennessee was like
it's
you're less reliant on team members
yeah or like you there's less like i'm
representing oakland there's none of
that
you don't want the pressure of a whole
city no i don't want the pressure off
your city like
i'm sorry yeah
i'm sorry oakland
god forbid you play for portland and and
you blow it
and you're so you go from being beloved
to yeah come on um
if you could have one snack food for the
rest of your go-to snack food you're
you're snacky and you just want to tear
in peanut butter always
satisfies and i always feel like it's
delicious either on toast or on
something but peanut butter is like yeah
something about it doesn't seem too
sweet it doesn't seem like how i was
being bad i i got you know
chocolate it's a little bit like this is
a healthy natural food they're nuts yeah
yeah are you do you tend to be
health-conscious are you i know
curious i'm like a type of like
wrong health conscious so i'm like well
i think i'm doing well
a person who really knows about food is
like that's no my friend
that's also sugar
they've cooked that those mushrooms and
those vegetables down to nothing that's
yeah yeah it's just yeah yeah that's
caramelized you're eating that's
caramelized yeah or it's things that i
would never expect like oh no no no
don't eat italian part you only cur
curly parsley you do not eat italian but
you know there's some yeah it's one
after the next so yeah in my mind i'm
like what's the problem that's a lot of
tofu and someone will be like well
you're not supposed to eat that much too
yeah
that's not healthy
um
what is your again this is not a good
lightning round question but
it's what you what is your favorite
movie or what is a movie that you um
that brings you a lot of my favorite
movie
yeah
i mean
brazil is like my favorite movie just
from like how it sort of
affected my life and how uh every time
i've seen it again i still always love
it and then
weirdly how
the world became like it when i saw it
when i was in college the world actually
did become
just like that with paranoia and
orwellians all the same fears and stuff
but um as far as like a movie that
really like still makes me excited i
would say the strangers do you ever see
the strangers from oh yeah
yes scott speedman yeah yeah yeah
oh why do you
like horror movies like that usually
like yeah that kind that kind is like i
just want my whole world to look like
that because you know they're like the
girl banks
on the door in the middle of the night
they're like who is this and this girl's
like
this tamara
no i think you've got the wrong house
are you sure
yeah oh it's so unsettling
it's so funny because there are sketches
on portlandia that have such a great
they're directed in such a great horror
ways they remind me of the strangers
like
the dj sketch is a little bit like that
oh i guess it is oh totally the the um
those angles even and the devices that
he uses
chrysler's so good at that at like um
borrowing from genres in a way that like
yeah
it's those some of those sketches are
genuinely unsettling
well i wonder if like just from that
movie might have had more of an effect
on me than i just always think about it
i'm like why i missed that movie i love
that movie so much i miss it i'm like
that's so i was just coming out again
that's a really funny movie to uh to
have like affection for i have so much
depression for it that's really funny i
can't wait to tell speed but that he'll
love that um if you had to live
somewhere else where would it be that's
an easy answer iceland
oh
man you gotta go
yeah what did you do there just on a
vacation you worked there yeah just
i like being there it's just
you know there's no trees it's almost
like volcanic rock everywhere
there's like little cool little
buildings
yeah just on this island where they're
like yeah we decided to make a country
here
there's our buildings you know what i
mean there's no it's almost i understand
that there was logic however many
centuries ago but i'm still like you
guys just went ahead and made a country
here everything is just like
everything's sort of boxy and white
you know
metallic a lot of metal buildings and
stuff and i don't know what i just love
it i love it there yeah dying to go and
the people i've heard are just love like
really warm
they're great they're they're great
did portlandia do they get uh when you
go to a country like that or
japan i don't know why i'm imagining you
in japan i feel like you were there not
too long yeah maybe
four years ago or something okay
do you get recognized there was did
portlandia cross over to countries once
in a while once in a while but like
i cherish it so much when someone says
something that to me i'm like hey they
know they know the show here and it
could be people or something
you know it is a wonderful shock when
someone who doesn't speak the same
language knows the show
i i really enjoy that that wow they
really are not from the states
and they know the show i i'm not
surprised i do find some of it so
accessible but but i know it's set in
such
american specific uh
locations yeah well although you know
i'm i mean who knows but like maybe
when i went to columbia a few years ago
and you could see the little portlandia
area there i don't mean i'm not saying
it's a portland no no like i kind of i
don't mean i'm just saying like that
vibe totally i saw it there you see it
in different cities not that it was
affected by the show but that no yeah
yeah whatever that is however that
happens
[Music]
if you could have dinner with three
people that are alive whom you've never
met uh you just want to sit down and
have a meal with them i'd like to um
talk to keith moon who he died in 1978.
how did he die again fred i think from
medication that was supposed to battle
uh alcoholism
oh oh wow wow
an overdose of that
what if everyone i think is just some
people who have od'd
that's okay you might feel left out
as the one non-od person
i wouldn't mind um nikolai tesla
just sort of like just just so that like
i could say i've met him
you know that's more of a name droppy
thing it's so like
like yeah yeah
yeah
totally normal like fun
we didn't talk at all about science even
we didn't talk about electricity
he didn't want to use asking also he was
asking me questions i was like you're
tesla
all right
and uh i this just came to me just just
hit me now maybe it's from
a similar time period but um clara beau
the silent film actor yes
i just want to meet her to tell her how
the rest of the century went you know
yeah
she sounds so historical it sounds like
somebody from so far in the past and my
grandmother
i was talking to her the other day she's
103 fred what so she was just you
remember clara
oh yeah she referenced her the other day
oh you probably don't know who that is
but i used to watch clara beau and mary
pickford and well by the way that's a
terrible impression my grandmother
that's just such a stereotypical old
lady impression she would be but maybe
that stereotype comes from how some old
people talk it's okay
that's okay
yeah
i don't want to offend anybody
she's your grandmother so yeah yeah
that's true
the only one mad will be her um yeah
yeah claire both that'd be cool i always
think about for some reason amelia
earhart
how i loved
i just because she was well first of all
just as like just obviously purely
superficially she was so beautiful but
obviously than what she did that she
i want to know i want to know the
mystery but i also want to um i don't
know i want to hear about her other
adventures i feel like everyone thinks
about her just in the context of her
death you know yeah in life like how did
she get to be in that position to be
doing i know that is substantial that's
not i know
no how does she know
that
isn't pretty incredible yeah years
before she was like but she was like i
have an idea this is my idea
yeah incredible but but she's another
one she's also
whenever i look at pictures of amelia
earhart she looks like from now there's
something about the way this is
photographed i'm like i feel like i know
that person it's like she's wearing a
halloween costume of an old-timey person
she has a modern beautiful face yeah
yeah
i feel like yeah
um have you has that ever struck you a
feeling of
we've met before we've known each other
before
are you are you at all open to that kind
of stuff well i'm not in the sense of
like
you know time being like before
i'm not anti-spiritual or any of those
things i'm pro-spiritual but i'm not
like completely scientific but i do
think that when something resonates
between two people i don't know why it
happens i think it's just like chemical
or something i think there's just like a
weird animal thing of like
you're a person i would say that like i
never had a time where i was like trying
to get to know you or like
i always felt like it was very easy to
know yeah you know what i mean something
else happens where like i don't even
know enough about your life to know this
but i'm like i'm sure we agree on a
billion things yeah yeah well i see i i
feel that way about you and to the point
where i just assume you're like that
with everyone like i've seen you on sets
i've seen the way people
um are around you you just seem
so easy to be around but i would imagine
everyone has that experience with you no
i mean that's very nice of you and by
the way i would say the same without you
but i think there's some people and it's
not even a bad thing where you're like
we're not you know completely in sync
that's a person from a different sort of
experience yeah
of course of course i i think of in
terms of like a road trip you know what
i mean like there's some people like
like i don't need to be on a road trip
with but i feel like
someone like yourself especially someone
like carrie yeah yeah this is a person
i could spit you know
drive cross-country with and i think
would be okay i i think it you feel it
by being relaxed like
i think it comes out when i feel relaxed
and i'm like i think i can kind of be
myself right now i think it's okay yeah
if i'm a little boring or a little dumb
right i i think i'll be okay i think
they get it right i think when that
happens
i felt that way um you know with a bunch
of people in snl too i mean a lot of
those people yeah you just i just felt
like we thought in a lot in the same
terms yeah yeah i i would say the only
the thing that i one of the things i
love in addition to that is i feel that
way
about around you but i also love when
you
you are so dry i've seen you do this
thing where you're
you're so dry that you'll say something
um
that i'm
like
i'm certain is a joke
but you commit to it uh without
winking or smirking at all that like
i start to wonder if it's real and and i
see people
get tricked by it like i i'm thinking of
a very specific moment on set where um
one of the makeup ladies was doing your
your makeup and you said um
she said something about your eyes like
you have really nice sizing and you said
i'm paraphrasing but you were like oh
thank you i actually ha i got uh an
implant i got this one of these is like
an animal eye and
it was like an absurd thing but you said
it in such a dry straight way that then
she i think she believe i started
wondering wait this can't be true but
it's
i and i wonder if some people are con
get confused i love that i find that so
fun and charming but i wonder if people
are like wait what well
my assumption is that they know that i'm
kidding
yeah you know
yeah that's my assumption i i don't like
to do the joke of like um i don't like
to do the ones where like it's too
realistic
where like it's it's where it's
plausible and like i don't like the
thing of like i really pulled one over
on them you know i don't like like i
told them i was bulgarian
you know
my brother and i used to do a bit with
our friend gear we would say
uh
something really mundane like um oh man
i
i i ate such a big lunch uh i'm so full
you know oh oh yeah
no i had a small lunch i'm [ __ ] with
you yeah i was like
why
yeah why that's not even funny did you
need to do that
yes yeah but psych
um yeah
who uh fred who's your favorite muppet
i mean i'm just partial to animal
although
um i always thought he was based on
keith's moon but then
i don't know where i heard it i thought
maybe he was ginger baker or something
like the way he would yeah yeah just
yeah but i like that he had a big drum
kit that they talked to yeah keith
moonish
drunk
and that was see i don't know enough
about that that was specific to keith
moon that was uh oh yeah like a lot of
like sort of flat and like a bunch of
like drums like sort of across a table
looks like or something you know
um
and
i'm just imagining you as a kid watching
animal like i want to do that um
yeah uh if you had to be one age for the
rest of your life physically what would
you pick
i will say about the muppets that kermit
is and was really famous
if that organization
a lot of people would pick kermit
because he was astoundingly famous
yes and so well liked i mean
yeah
who didn't like at least like kermit
whether he was your favorite muppet he
was sensitive and honest and
but so well known i bet you should go to
any country you're like who's that
because they don't they don't know the
others they don't know gonzo or whoever
you don't think
no not as much i think that most people
be like
kermit even if they didn't speak the
language
when when you were in brazil was that
during a time
were the ages you were there like a
muppet were you into them no that was um
the time i was there
it was all i think things were pretty
mickey mouse
oh oh oh yeah huh you know also latin
america is very mickey mousing
right like i
okay
i think these are latin american
characters
because it's so it was so familiar it
like rolls off their tongue uh
yeah and it could be one why not those
characters are sure about i'm sure they
would universe
but yeah in venezuela to my my yeah so
my father's
my father my father's german but
half he's half german half korean
right and for a while i've read that is
this true that you thought you're and
this is not a good lightning round
question but that you thought it's
fascinating uh you thought your
grandfather was japanese he posed as a
japanese person yes uh because of the
korean japanese
yeah because of racism against koreans
wow so he was like i'm not korean i'm
japanese
oh my god
did he was that something you discovered
later did he
kind of come out as a korean oh no no no
no i found out later through all the
records and stuff they're like we tried
to find your grandfather and
his name doesn't go back past this oh my
god
so we found this other name and that's
your grandfather's so it was used to be
kuni this japanese name and they're like
no it's pak pak
and you're being very humble about your
your lineage now but i i also read that
that poc that korean side goes back
centuries and
a bit of a aristocratic like
legacy yeah my grandfather was a dancer
he's a choreographer and right um
i'm very artistic
very you know him impressive
i've met him a couple of times
but he traveled the world a lot and he
was wow but i went to japan and i saw
his
dance studio and had like a little mini
museum upstairs
and he would the pictures were
him as different characters
you know in his dances he would do like
these different characters and stuff oh
wow did your father ever say
i recognize some of what you're doing in
his in his work and in his
and not that much
my dad was happy about it all but he
never we never really got into the i
mean i'm sure we've had talked about it
a little bit but there was never a
moment of like oh my god you're doing
exactly what cooney's doing
wow
that was so cool
um
uh would you rather be called fred uh
oh sorry if you could be reincarnated as
a non-human animal
what would you pick i would say a um
a bat maybe
that's a pretty cool existence
i like that they're nocturnal
i think they look you're at night
yeah
they just look great
yeah and you get to be a mammal still
but also fly around
yeah
i think
because being a bird i think it sounds
so stressful
they always seem stressed it's like
they're so everything you read about
them
you could get eaten by a hawk or another
bird i'm just like this is
enough this is
so or a cat
or people
forget it
don't be a bird what a payoff they're
like you want to fly okay that sounds
great i'll take it all right but you
will always be scared
why i could just fly away
nope
another bird will eat you
it'll swoop down
there's danger everywhere
snakes eating your eggs
out of here that's not in existence
you're flying into windows when are you
safe yeah
yeah that's right when do you realize
you're right i never thought about that
when can you relax whereas bats yeah
i've been to that bridge in austin
they're just yeah they're sleeping all
day under there they're relaxing like we
have our thing you know people are
scared enough of them that they're like
let's just
create a distance so they're sort of
left alone a little bit
yeah yeah then at night there's just
like let's just go eat a ton of food
yeah no one wants their skin really like
birds people want those feathers
can you imagine being a bird and seeing
a pen like
like people are sick
it's right pulling out our balloons
um
yeah just eating us but and using as
much of us as you can is kind of nice um
uh what is your
would you rather be called unattractive
or unfunny fred
i don't know if i
worry about either like
i don't
that's never been what
you know
like where you've got compelled me that
i don't i'm i feel like
i'm okay looking but i'm not like
you know
i i don't if i was
if someone thinks of me as unattractive
i'm
great
yeah it's not a source of like value to
you
no not at all yeah and then
you know i don't think i don't think i
even care about i'm funny if someone
said i was like
okay great i don't know i'm just doing
wow i'm doing what i can but if i'm
unfunny by me it's really admirable um
almost done which golden girl do you
most identify with dorothy blanche rose
or sophia
i don't know why i'm going to say branch
oh yeah well blanche we always think i
think it was like a good time
she was a good time
yeah
there's something i mean obviously
they're all funny but there's something
really
i don't know something funny about her
what her character was yeah yeah
um
yeah what was the big show for you
growing up what was like a uh a really
comedically like an inspirational show
saturday night live in high school it
was oh yeah i'm i love saturday night
live i love it i love it then loved it
in high school loved it in college
always loved snl ev every new cast and
now i watch it i watched it live last
night i love it
that's
so when you that first
performance was it
god then what a thrill that must have
been
do you still remember that first
the first one i remember it so vividly
that like it's still echoing it still
echoes inside me of like
i cannot believe it like this
shock
it is
it's fictional it's like i cannot
believe that like
somehow i used to love that show and
then that i was on even once even once
yeah
mind-blowing to me and then
as i grew up and or as you know i kept
going i'd meet other cast members i
can't believe i'm meeting them oh wow
you know lorraine newman or will ferrell
or whoever you know mike myers
just
i
because their voices i would hear them
on my tv or like in that studio that
sound
and then there they are to think that i
was ever on that show
i'm always amazed
and that's really cool so fred does then
does it raise the stakes then to the
point where you get nervous did you like
i'm thinking specifically when you do uh
jan and garth was the the two the
characters that uh oh garth and cassidy
no no
yeah it's a little different than that
and that like i felt so familiar with it
that that was almost a case of seeing an
old friend
uh so when i was there i wasn't like
what is this i was like oh please i know
i know i know your output
so i think i get the idea of what you're
you're trying to do it felt actually
less
it was like less pressure
weird yeah that makes sense yeah you
know just just to sort of like because
not
not about how big it is but just what
they do i'm like oh i way no i know this
kind of sketch you know the
commercial i know that we can update
peace i know what you're talking about
when you say i should do it this way
uh-huh oh god that's that's interesting
and and
that's because a lot of that was
improvised right you had you you'd have
to be comfortable oh
oh yeah yeah or like nicholas fame that
that was improvised and so was garden
cat yeah but everything that was the
only thing
that i did
amazing god
missed those characters uh uh really
quickly dogs are cats
cats
yeah
okay
obviously um and
do you have any a cat do you have i
don't but i i feel like you're
i'm just i feel like i work too much you
know to like be able to
really take care of an animal but um
yeah cats all the way
what are you doing now fred by the way i
mean we don't have to if it's something
we can't talk about i don't even know
but uh i mean i didn't know how what
their policy is on it but it's
a show for apple tv and it's um
cecily strong she's doing a show it's
like kind of like a musical
she's so funny
so it's kind of like a musical and then
i just have a role in it so this is
nothing produced or
written it's just like they asked me to
do a role in it but it's so because of
kovid
it's i can't fly in and out and like i
have to be in vancouver and stay here
and like
so
great but it's just it's a show not just
a show but it's a show for apple tv
okay okay oh fun um uh okay well my
friend oh beetles are the rolling stones
we've already covered
yeah i mean i'm gonna say beetles but um
the older i get
the less i'm like i just i just feel
like everyone is great every older i get
the more i'm like
every band is all fantastic i know
yeah
just because i know how hard it is to
get there until like for a band to go
right or i'm just let's give them all a
break
what who do you miss seeing live the
most i mean now like obviously it's it's
a time where we can't do that who's
what's the ban that like once this is
all kind of
we're able to do things like that again
who who are you really jones in this
scene i had tickets to see craftwork
this whole summer i was i was going to
go to three shows maybe two shows
and i've seen them a bunch
um
and
uh uh who knows when that will happen
again
yeah and and i know that's what everyone
we're all saying and stuff and i'm sure
there's a version of him but i think
it's gonna be a while to like that
feeling of like a real huge crowd
that is gonna when is that gonna happen
i don't know i know i'm i'm imagining
like an outdoor i used to every every
year i'd go to this my brother and a
friend of ours would go to um
have you been to martha texas um i've
never been no
oh you'd love it fred but there's a
friend of mine owns this place called
alcosmico it's like a
airstream trailers and teepees and stuff
it's um
friends with carrie liz lambert oh liz
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know yeah uh
and there's a music festival there so i
imagine something like that
where
you get outside you can kind of keep a
little bit it's not super crowded
i'm hoping i don't know but yeah i mean
i guess
sure that'll be great i know i'll love
it obviously but that feeling
of like oh this is too crowded you know
in a good way like oh this is too
crowded all night
yeah and like
that's done yeah for a while well
yeah now i'm imagining like punk
audiences like the audiences that you
are most familiar with that yeah you
want like uh the energy
yeah
it's fun you know
yeah
um well i mean this is one of my
the best things about doing this is
getting to
spend time with people like you and i'm
this is you you're one of the my
favorites
so admirer
feeling is mutual and also how about
that we get to catch up that's really
nice uh it's the it's the best and once
you're really lucky
what's the project you're working on
that you said you're working on tuesday
oh it's really fun fred it's called
creep show it's um
remember that it's like the horror
anthology oh yeah yeah this is the first
time i've worked during this
this thing so i
i don't know i guess i think some things
are back some things are bad yeah well i
mean have you started yet i mean you
wouldn't i started i had to do a
two-week quarantine and all that stuff
so two weeks oh yeah in this room right
here
wow
yeah wow were you climbing the walls i
actually had arranged for an electronic
drum kit oh cool fred's showing me oh
that's cool so i could sort of put on
headphones and
yeah and practice and stuff
oh fun uh that's cool well man enjoy it
uh i just still love getting to catch up
with you thank you sam here i'm glad we
did this
[Music]
well that happened that happened oh he
did a similar so that happened yeah i
mean it's just sort of like innoce
there's an innocence and a a curiosity
in his voice he's puckish he is puckish
he is punkish god i'd love to see him
play um puck yeah
yeah if we shadows have offended think
but this and all this men did that you
have but slumbered here while these
visions did appear and this weak and
idle theme no more yielding but a dream
well gentles do not reprehend if you
pardon we will men it's so impressive
that you know that as i am an honest
puck if we have under unearned luck [ __ ]
okay well um god is he i heard you
laughing i christian was listening to it
with his headphones and it's rare to
hear you by yourself laugh out loud
that is true i never i almost never
laugh out loud unless i'm with people
very rare but he uh tickles me
he really tickles me he is um he has one
hell of a special brain you know what
makes him puckish is that he
he has this uh it's a very subtle
but it's perceptible like a mischievous
gleam in his eye and like
it kind of colors his voice in his voice
yeah it's funny there's something like
um very innocent and sweet i mean he
reminds me a little bit of michael sarah
in that way yeah you know yeah but
michael also has like a cutting
really
sardonic they remind me of each other a
little bit there's like a levity to him
yeah but he's also at the same time
clearly
very very passionate about certain
things like drumming like comedy so he
has this like uh like intense
passion and enthusiasm for things but
everything is
light at the same time it's a very
unusual combination it is it's a very
likeable conversation like when we did
that we talked about the um mafia zoom
thing that we did and but right before
we started playing he was kind of
catching up because there were a bunch
of people from snl on the zoom and he
was catching up with some of them and he
was just so like in intrigued by what
they were saying and
somebody said they were in i forget
where it was you know i'm in new zealand
it was an intriguing place but he was
like wow you know and he wanted to know
about and he was very
he had this wide-eyed curiosity yeah
like a wonderful a real like
which is a child-like quality well he
had that with you in this conversation
too he gets very excited about things
and it doesn't
feel even remotely put on oh not at all
yeah because
we both know plenty of people who
put that on
a lot of people in your industry
are very good at putting that on i'm
thinking of a few right now oh there's
many
or like even just like dialing it up of
course degrees but yeah he doesn't he
seems completely honest but what's but
that's also what makes him i mean here's
the tricky part it makes him a great
actor and it makes him
i think one of the funniest people i've
ever been around because he's so dry
he's just so good at delivering that's
why he's
that show is so brilliant because he's
able to like
mine things out of human being he's able
to
display areas of human behavior that are
so subtle i was impressed by how little
you
um chris farley showed him oh good i was
expecting a lot more like remember
because i knew how much you had been
watching the show leading up to talking
to him so i thought for sure
you were gonna reference a bunch of very
specific
um sketches and you only mentioned a
couple and like a couple characters that
you'd done where you were curious and
and his answers were really interesting
like nicholas feyne oh yeah came from a
combination of marc maron and david
cross and yeah you would never think
that no
that that was really interesting to
listen to but um it was funny after you
kind of went back and talked about
previous characters he said in the most
gentle
sweet way how he doesn't really enjoy
revisiting yeah
things like that things he had done but
he wasn't you know he's totally fine
talking about it
how like kind he was so you know it's
funny that he was so kind about it his
delivery was so like gentle that i
didn't even register it as having in any
way
been in relation to what i had said
uh-huh you know that it was maybe i
should take i didn't take this at all
social cue to maybe stop talking about
it but it was funny he couldn't quite
explain why he doesn't like doing it but
he's like i just don't i don't want to
wear the wigs and
you know we're only getting we're
getting older that's that was funny the
idea yes imagine an older face well it
made me think about uh we recently saw
an episode of alf do you remember this
and the gilligan's island cast was on
the show and alpha's in the like
late 80s i think and gilligan's island
had been off the earth i think i'm
getting this wrong probably but at least
10 years they were like a much older cat
and they were just playing themselves
i've seen other versions of this like in
the
in man on the moon that that
the andy kaufman movie like they have
some
character some actual people playing
themselves and it's always weird to see
somebody
do
that you know like trying wearing the
same same costume the older face yeah
speaking of if they were ever to make a
uh biopic of bob denver oh from
gilligan's island uh-huh there's certain
people
are you gonna say me
no
there's just certain people that i
certain actors i know who might be a
good fit for that role who are you gonna
say i was gonna say yeah
i was like i started getting offended
like well i should play bob denver
the lightning round he had
he had an instinct to
and he admitted it right away which is
very honest he had an instinct to
um
give a more showy answer i forget what
it was i um
oh the emoji oh yeah and he was like
he didn't do it but he admitted
he his first instinct was he wanted to
sound impressive yeah or say something
and
he's so
smart and self-analytical and honest
that he pointed that out i thought that
was
um it's so fitting that that's how his
brain works well you touched on
something that i think is really
important in his comedy and and what
makes him so great and and
is that he's honest i mean there's an
honesty in all of those portrayals and
and it's not always the most he he can
look foolish and he can look at but he's
he finds such honesty in human behavior
so such detailed honesty
i think you have to be honest with
yourself and about your own behavior in
order to be so good at recognizing
nuances and other behaviors i wonder i i
i would imagine
i don't know i mean i think you do i
think he's just
and and he's also he points things out
there's something very perceptive about
him the same with carrie i think that's
why that shows i think and it's just
being super comfortable in your own skin
oh yeah i yeah genuinely believe him
when he said he doesn't
um care if someone doesn't think he's
attracted he's like between those two
things i thought about it he's like i i
don't care if
someone doesn't find me he's like i
think i'm okay looking but it doesn't
matter and and he said a similar thing
about being funny too i was like if you
know you don't find me funny i guess
that's okay too well you see that in in
his again not to keep going back to
portland but i see that in so much of
his work too is that he's he can distort
his face he can look really bizarre on
that show and he makes faces as
certainly as nina in the nan uh lance
and nina schedule he like he he knows
that it's funny that he's strange
looking as nina i mean that's part of
the comedic
at all afraid to look silly not at all
he makes the crazy faces fearless it's
it's a and it's i think that like you
said requires a total lack or at least a
near total lack of vanity yeah he's like
vanity-free yeah
yeah god it's such a gift for a comedian
to be on some honest
some of those answers that he loves this
so weird he loves the strangers
he likes right away right away oh that's
an easy one i want to live in iceland
yeah
and the more he described it the more
confusing
the answer became to me well it's great
they're these everything's like metal
and snowy and there's like not a tree in
sight yeah it's all and you were like oh
yes yeah i thought great i thought he
was going to talk about like how it's
like an elfin yeah i could see him being
i could see him acclimating to any
environment you know but the fact that
he loves that i know so weird and and uh
charming perfect yeah you know he did
something when he was on comedians and
cars getting copy and jerry seinfeld
went to the bathroom uh-huh and he just
stayed there and fred pretended like
there was still somebody there that he
was talking to he just finds like he
finds humor in
he could find it in any circumstance
he's that to me is
so rare such a gift he's like such a
brilliant clown you know that sounds
like an insult i know i know it's no i
mean it is the highest to me it's the
highest compliment uh
so funny when he said he wants to have
tesla at his dinner at his dinner
because he just wants to name drop him
he's like i just want to tell people
that i know him
you guys talked about people having
chemistry and where that comes from and
we don't know no one really knows for
sure but
and i think this is a really good way of
measuring it is who you want to go on a
road trip with because there's something
very specific
about doing that i think it's just
because if you can be next to someone
for a long time and not feel
the need to talk and like be comfortable
in silence yeah i think that is like
the ultimate test for
whether you're comfortable with someone
you're not and like genuinely compatible
i mean that's the iron it's like the
biggest test for compatibility is
how well you
exist in silence
yeah yeah i think that's true or in very
like i mean which is similar to what you
said in
mundane circumstances
like
at breakfast i mean sometimes i look at
couples that i mean i know this is a
cliche cliche thing to point out but
like i look at couples at breakfast
sitting there and sometimes i admire
couples sitting in silence like reading
a paper or like
but other times you can feel the
chasm between them you know it's it's
very rare to yeah but i've become much
less judgmental when i see that now
because having you're in one well no i'm
more aware of what it really means you
know when i was younger i think i felt
more oh they ran out of things
differently exactly i felt more of an
urge to fill the space when and we've
both been in relationships with people
where
you have that instinct to like
fill the space with things and and and
keep the conversation going but
it's not until you feel completely
comfortable
not feeling the space where i think
you're in a good i mean not just
romantic relationship but any sort of
well relationship and i think it when
the person is so comfortable and i'm
thinking about last week's guest uh
allison who you know talking about betty
said she's the most comfortable person
in her skin i think fred is similar to
that like there's this very like
relaxed and of course i admire him so
much i want to like
impress him but maybe you just happen to
have a lot of chemistry with him so
that's why you feel especially
comfortable
not maybe talking constantly right maybe
and because i had worked with him and
i've been i had spent enough time around
him and
yeah he's always been so
friendly to me so like um
just so nice to me i i never feel like
he's judging me or you know so i don't
have that insecurity in that sense of
like oh god i gotta like perform you
know but i do with a lot of people
i think uh when you saw me laughing it
was it was when he uh when i was
laughing out loud
when you asked me if you'd prefer cats
or dogs and he
the way he answered and made me laugh so
hard because he goes cats
oh yeah yeah obvious oh yeah
yeah another thing he hasn't gone it was
funny it was funny on two levels one
that he said it in a way that like
oh you should know the answer to this
but also that
i think he was our first guest that
definitively picked cats yes and there's
something funny about alison free oh
yeah but but then it's you think about
it it's like yeah i would have guessed
that totally
he is a guy that i can i sometimes find
that strange there's something cat like
about he has he's got feline energy
he does he's i don't know what dog he
would be he's um like i said he's just
more sort of elegant and subdued and
he at that which i think comes with
confidence sometimes i think it's it's
it um yeah i i think it's speaks to that
in him his like sense of he's
comfortable with himself yes and he
doesn't at all feel and i've always and
often times with especially people i
admire that that um makes me nervous i
feel like if somebody is just kind of
holding back and but he doesn't do it at
all
for like power or any effect it's just
very natural and very easy going it's
weird it's like a combination of holding
back subdued but easy going that's a
rare combo let's read a letter okay this
is uh from aaron johnston subject
postpartum pals
hello justin and company my name is
aaron and i live in a suburb of dallas
texas with my husband four and a half
year old daughter and just over the
summer we welcomed a fresh baby boy into
our little family a fresh
it's funny to think about a fresh human
i wonder if she means that he's sassy
yeah
he's a sassy little infant
uh he came out just spewing sass with
placenta all over um being pregnant
giving birth and having a newborn all
during the pandemic has been a very
strange experience oh my god i bet
i'm a new listener to the show a new
listener to the show as i discovered you
late one night while feeding the baby
i was searching podcasts and yours
popped up your show quickly became part
of my midnight routine it keeps me awake
and entertained oh it's nice
awake being more important and
entertained a bonus yeah i bet there
were even times that i worried i would
wake up the sleeping babe in my arms
because i would start to giggle about a
story you and christian were telling oh
i've enjoyed your show so much i started
listening to short snippets while doing
the dishes and it feels
like a very teeny tiny vacation
god is that nice to hear this is when i
realized you guys have been like my
postpartum pals during the strange time
your kind thoughtful and funny stories
helped me get through some very long
nights and i sincerely thank you that is
so nice
uh thank you aaron postpartum pals i
like that it's tough to say no one's
ever referred to me as a postpartum pal
no i like it though i mean i think
that's a very rare thing to be referred
to of course
now onto important business that was
important to us
you're posting remember people are
listening oh yeah um
it's not just about us right you're
right in fact it should almost not be at
all at all i know i shouldn't indulge in
things that only i really like that's
every 20 20 thing that yeah you do i
know all right this is 2021 me getting
back to business in hand that people
will be entertained by
uh back to aaron's letter would you
rather be spit up
would you rather be spit up on every
hour but at random intervals yes this
includes the middle of the night or have
to hold your p for hours at a time and
only get to go twice at day
but you get to choose the time
twice a day twice a day yeah um you only
get to go twice a day but you have to
choose the time
god peeing
that means you wouldn't be able to drink
that much and
it being spit up on i guess she means by
a baby not by a human but uh without
explaining it no
oh oh she does i'm sorry oh yeah sorry
in fact she's so great she even included
a um an asterisk which is usually a
picture
the throw up
i know the fresh
spit up i know that not everyone this is
her asterisk the footnote i know that
not everyone is as familiar with spit up
as i currently am but if you have no if
you have not experienced spit up spit up
down your neck chest back imagine
thinned oatmeal
that is slightly warmer
than your body temperature and smells
like sour milk shooting out at a
surprising speed when you least expect
it now i'm leaning more towards the
being
i've experienced that i have two
um but i i don't remember it smelling
like that sour milk is a horrible smell
remember what does that remind you of
spoiled milk uh boy scout camp summer
camp oh yeah yeah that and working at
the coffee shop yeah that too um
okay but not about us it's not about us
so why do we have to
no it's not about us um okay i would do
i would
every hour but at random intervals [ __ ]
that must be that must be tough uh or
have to hold your pee for hours at a
time i guess you get used to just
drinking differently you know you would
you would drink a lot twice a day
and just
evacuate you know at no i didn't think
about that at the appropriate time but i
even that i don't know if that's
enough
urine like i i think no matter
what even if those are too big peas
that doesn't feel like an a healthy
enough amount of fluid you're getting
awesome
and i i would say as long as i can sleep
through the night and
these spit up what doesn't rouse me from
sleep yeah then you wake up with like
frosty fine i'd get used to a routine of
you know showering first thing when i
got up and showering the dried spittle
off yeah baby if it didn't wake me up i
would have to you know put a sound thing
on and yeah
and eye mask and earplugs so if i could
sleep through the night then i would
pick that because it seems really
unhealthy to only pee twice a day it
does and not to i mean this goes against
the lesson i just learned about people
listening but i've also been peeing a
little bit more at night because uh
you're not as young no spring chicken my
prostate's not um
all fresh like your baby's prostate is
isn't that weird to think of little
infants having prostates
it's not pleasant to think about yeah i
know i know um but uh yeah i would
probably choose that too you know both
have to want to get spit up on rather
than only peeing twice a day because
also i don't love that that smell but
you again you get used to it it's not
that bad yeah
yeah yeah i would do that as well okay
great question
and uh and disgusting yeah yeah one my
favorite kind yeah uh thoughtful and
disgusting
classic aaron johnston
uh i hope you guys have a happy holiday
this back to aaron i hope you guys have
a happy holiday season and a happy new
year i'm hopeful that 2021 will be a
better year for everyone but i'm not
holding my breath
um
warmest regards aaron yeah i am holding
my breath me too i think it because
aaron you wrote that just before um the
new year came also and now we're in the
new year it's 2021 now yeah and i'm here
from the future to tell you that things
are looking up
yeah and it's got to i mean right it can
only
it's been a pandemic it's like we're
gonna have the vaccine things are good
that alone is gonna change things
exponentially well that's also why the
roaring twenties and i have another
roaring twenties that's what i go real
boom of course yeah and and for aaron
specifically like she's gotten through
now the infant stage which of the
throwing of the spinning up and soon
it's it's going to get a lot more fun
having that kid right and now her sassy
baby is not as fresh it's not going to
have any memory of having gone through a
pandemic that's true and he or she is
just going to get to live in this
blissful roaring 20s experience until
the next pandemic 100 years from now
actually her baby's a lot like our
grandmother was uh during the spanish
flu she was an infant during that time
doesn't really remember it was probably
spitting up she definitely doesn't
remember it well she said she has vague
memories of like her uncle taking care
of you really yeah i think so she's very
smart she remembers going to italy when
mussolini was in power when she was like
seven so she's got a hell of a memory
anyway um i'm hoping your fresh baby uh
lives as long as she does and has an
equally fresh memory and is equally good
for the world fingers crossed yeah um
anyway thanks aaron and thank you also
to
our very special guests that i hope he's
listening genius g he yeah
you were so emphatic that you bumped
your head
on the little
what do you call this a microphone
microphone like a spit cover what do you
call this it's not a spit cover
what's it for a screen yeah one of those
little microphones what would you say
it's a microphone i guess
okay
well um
a good guest for um the first episode of
the year i think oh yeah what a way to
start a year that will be better let's
be positive yes let's um let's hold our
breath
no that's not a good thing to do let's
just breathe easy let's breathe a little
easier because this year yeah let's hope
for the best and um
thanks to although eric i appreciate
your pessimism aaron i'm often
pessimistic and let's hope and you know
what in this new year i'm going to try
to wrap up the show a little bit more
succinctly so far so good
you're going to say that happy new year
to all of you and if you'd like to write
in
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short as hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted by you christian
long uh also a producer another producer
on this one is
megan monaco senior producer is michelle
miesh lance audio engineer is a man
named sergio enriquez the executive
producers fernan lopez and
marshall louis who just had a baby
himself a fresh baby congratulations to
him all of this is done through a
company called wondering
[Music]
i would much rather have to hide um the
fart the the burps
it's easier to hide a fart
i know there's a smell factor but that's
what you're not i don't think
considering enough but even if you get
caught on the rare occasion in your life
when someone's like
did you fart i smell no but it's
actually been where
it's like people see it you know but
that's the thing with farts
because there's the potential for them
to smell bad
you can never really
risk it you can't fart around people you
fart around people yeah
what yeah
i just hope it doesn't smell yeah well
right here though in a closed even
farting church
in church let's say what am i some
devout of course i'd fart in church
a big church you would a crazy example
oh i wouldn't i far in front of friends
i've heard in front of you
and me is different than like if you're
at a restaurant i farted a restaurant
i i know you're such a freight farter oh
yeah i fart all the time
in fact i was never i almost never hold
my farts you're kidding no i almost
never hold on if you're on a date first
date you fart that's different i mean
those are weird exceptions but they are
i'm not a fart holder
you